Your car began its life billions of years
ago.
Billions of miles away in deep space.
The things that make up cars.
Those atoms, most of them were forged well
before our Earth was born.
You think your car is a clunker?
It's actually 13.8 billion years old.
All right, Let's do it, sir.
So what's the stuff that cars are made of?
Best way to find out.
Tear one apart.
Iron, plastics, oils and rubber are the
first to go.
Another half hour or so, this baby is going
to be completely stripped.
I can't wait to see it.
Then aluminum, silicon, copper and finally
precious metals like platinum and gold.
Each of these materials is crucial for
building a car.
But in the earliest days of the universe,
none of them existed.
13.8 billion years ago.
Time and space are created in the Big Bang.
The early universe is filled with nothing
but energy.
After the Big Bang, it was just a chaotic
glob of stuff.
Nothing like what you see today.
As the early universe cools, the energy gives
way to unstable matter and antimatter.
Then protons and neutrons.
And finally atoms.
But none of them are iron, silicon or
carbon.
These vast, gassy clouds are mostly
hydrogen.
Something had to happen to give us everything
else and everything was actually made from
hydrogen building blocks.
An atom of hydrogen is the simplest and
lightest atom in the universe, just a single,
positively charged proton bound to a single
electron.
The universe then builds up bigger atoms
like carbon and iron by fusing hydrogen atoms
together.
Everything starts from simpler origins.
An iron atom is actually lots and lots of
simple hydrogen atoms that were stuck
together.
At first, this versatile proton building
block doesn't want to stick.
Protons are positively charged, so as you
push them closer together, they're going to
resist coming closer together.
They really don't want to hang out.
This repulsion makes the early universe a
maelstrom of hydrogen atoms swerving to avoid
each other.
But if you can get them to a point where you
can shove them together enough, at some point
you're going to lock together.
Pushing atoms together so strongly they stick
is called nuclear fusion.
It's the first key step for turning a
universe full of gas into one filled with the
ingredients for people, cars and planets.
So how do you get two atoms to fuse?
This guy's been doing it in his garage since
he was 14.
Taylor Wilson is obsessed with nuclear
fusion.
They didn't get power from the laundry room
now.
Taylor passes a high voltage through a small
spherical cage that sits inside the reactor.
The negatively charged cage quickly draws
the hydrogen ions inside it.
So it's taking all those ions and sucking
them towards the center.
And as they fly in, they get confined and
hopefully they collide with each other and
fuse.
The temperature of the atoms inside the cage
is now so great that hydrogen atoms are
fusing together, creating heavier helium
atoms and a burst of energy hotter than the
surface of the sun.
It's that little tiny blob of plasma inside
those grid wires that's kind of like a star
in a jar.
13 billion years ago.
The universe uses gravity to fuse atoms
instead of an electrical cage.
Across the cosmos, vast clouds of hydrogen
gas collapse under their own gravity.
Pressure and temperature build as more and
more gas gets sucked in.
Eventually, fusion sparks deep inside the
core of these giant balls of gas, and the
first stars start to manufacture many of the
heavy elements that make up your car today.
A star is basically a machine for turning
lighter elements into heavier elements.
Fusion takes place only inside the core of
these first stars, fusing hydrogen atoms
together to create helium.
And when all the hydrogen in the core is
used up, the star finds a new fuel to burn.
After you burn hydrogen to form helium, the
core of the star begins to collapse and get
hotter. And there is enough energy then to
fuse three helium nuclei into carbon.
And then that fuses to form nitrogen,
oxygen, silicon, iron.
But this incredible production line of
elements can't go on forever.
The heavier atoms you ram together, the less
energy you get out.
So you turn hydrogen into helium.
Helium becomes carbon, nitrogen, oxygen.
But every time there's a bit less energy to
be had until you get to Ion.
The iron that is in your car is actually
essentially a deadly poison when it comes to
a star. It's robbing that star of the heat
needed to keep itself up.
So the star collapses, dies and explodes.
At the moment, you create iron in the core.
I mean, literally the fraction of a second.
I'm not kidding. That's how dramatic and
weird the steel in your car is.
The explosion called a supernova, is one of
the brightest and most violent events in the
universe.
It releases enough energy to dwarf what the
sun puts out over its entire lifetime.
And all of the elements that it has created
are then dispersed out into space.
The gassy remains of the explosion are called
a supernova remnant.
An expanding bubble of hydrogen gas from the
outer layers of the star that mixes with
stardust, the carbon, oxygen, silicon and
iron from its core.
And this same 13 billion year old Stardust
helped you drive to work last week.
This was once in the core of a dying star.
And who knows, maybe some of the iron atoms
in this break disc were forged in the heart
of the very first generation of stars that
illuminated the universe.
When you're pumping iron, you're pumping a
universe.
The first generation of stars created the
materials in a car's chassis, body,
windshield and seats.
But we're still missing key components like
the copper for the car's electrics.
To create this crucial metal, a new
generation of stars must die an even stranger
death. Picture our universe as the very
first
stars come to the end of their lives.
The early Milky Way is filled with flashes
as star after star explodes.
These violent supernovas hurl a rich
cocktail of heavy elements into space.
The carbon, silicon, aluminum and iron atoms
that will one day build our cars here on
Earth.